general Jim mattis quits as Secretary of
Defense president Trump initiates DEFCON
1 on a government shutdown and the stock
market tumbles again it's the yeren
episode of the ben shapiro show
well this is the final live episode this
year I know brush away those tears it's
okay it'll be all right we'll get
through this together and then we'll be
back energized and refreshed in the new
year I know I will minutes go vacation
next week I hope that you're also having
a vacation next week but first we want
to make sure that you are all up-to-date
with the latest news which is crazy I
have to say the season finale of trump
it's really ending on a cliffhanger all
right like as we go into the new year I
mean there are a lot of cliffhangers
that have yet to be resolved really a
strong tease for the next season of
Trump the show we'll get to all that
interest one second first let's talk
about how you send packages this holiday
season this Christmas season because it
is indeed Christmas you know kind of
kinda wow it goes you're not sending
those packages if you are you're late
but if you're sending Christmas packages
you want to be using stamps calm why
would you use stamps calm because it
means that you don't have to drag all
your presents over to the post office
wait in line and then go through the
whole rigmarole instead you can make
sure that you are sending proper postage
at home print it out stick it on the
package the post office picks it up it's
so good and then you're done Sam
Stockholm brings all the services of the
u.s. post office directly to your
desktop you can buy in print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer
and printer and then the mail carrier
just picks it up no trips to the post
office required it could not be easier
you can print postage at any day at any
time stamps comm is always open and
stamps calm not only saves you time it
saves you money because stamps.com helps
you print the right amount of postage
every single time we use stamps comm
here at the Daily wire offices I use
stamps calm in my own personal life for
Hanukkah presents and also for nice
things for people around the Christmas
time I use stamps because it is so good
for all of the aforementioned reason and
right now you too can enjoy the stamps
comm service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
ends digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps comm click on
that microphone at the top of the home
page type in promo code Shapiro that is
stamps comm and use that promo code
Shapiro for the special deal four-week
trial plus postage ends digital scale
without long term commitments stamps
comm promo code Shapiro alright so last
episode of the year there's a lot going
on a lot going on so yesterday the
Secretary of Defense Jim mattis General
Jim mattis who is one of the most
beloved members of the Trump
administration by the general public and
by the Republican base at large he
decided that he was out he issued his
resignation letter he will be leaving as
early as February his resignation letter
is quite brood
but to understand what he's talking
about you first have to understand what
it was that triggered the resignation so
a little bit of background info Jim
mattis is very close to General John
Kelly who is the chief of staff inside
the White House when John Kelly left
that probably set the clock ticking on
when mattis was going to leave but as
recently as a few days ago it has been
reported mattis was telling friends and
family that he was going to stay on and
see this thing through because he wanted
to make sure that the Pentagon was still
being well led no matter who was
presidents of the United States well all
of that changed after the president of
the United States Donald Trump decided
to precipitously announce a pullout from
Syria and not just that he's apparently
preparing now a substantial withdrawal
of US troops from Afghanistan according
to The Wall Street Journal apparently he
wants to pull down about 7,000 of the
remaining 14 thousand US troops he wants
to bring half of them home in the coming
weeks the start of a total pullout that
could take at least as many months
according to The Wall Street Journal a
day after a contested decision to pull
American military forces from Syria
officials said on Thursday the president
Trump has ordered the start of a
reduction of American forces in
Afghanistan more than 7,000 American
troops will begin to return home from
Afghanistan in the coming weeks a US
official said the move will come as the
first stage of a Phase two drawdown and
the start of a conclusion to the 17 year
war that officials say could take at
least many months there now more than
fourteen thousand US troops in
Afghanistan Trump announced on Twitter
on Wednesday that he would pull all of
the more than 2,000 American troops in
Syria as The Wall Street Journal notes
taken together the Syria withdrawal and
the likely Afghan drawdown represent a
dramatic shift in the u.s. approach to
military engagement in hot spots around
the world reflecting mr. trump's
aversion to long-running military
engagements with their high costs and
American casualties a senior US official
said I think it shows how serious the
president is about wanting to come out
of conflicts I think he wants to see
viable options about how to bring
conflicts to a close now all of this was
not driven by the best foreign policy
advisors around him I do not think this
is the position of nikki Haley I do not
think this is the position of John
Bolton I do not think this is the
position of Mike Mahon Peyo I don't
think this is a position of Jim mattis I
think this is president Trump talking to
outside folks including the dictator of
Turkey air21 who wanted him out of Syria
I think he's being he's talking to folks
like rand paul and tucker carlson who
are telling him to double down on his
views with regard to afghanistan a lot
of that is speculation but knowing the
president talks to outside sources
none of that would be
surprising the problem is that decisions
like this actually have consequences so
let's take Syria first the president
tweeted out regarding Syria yesterday so
hard to believe he's very angry at
Senator Lindsey Graham who's come out
against him on this is so hard to
believe that Lindsey Graham would be
again saving soldier lives and billions
of dollars why are we fighting for our
enemy Syria by staying in killing Isis
for them Russia Iran and other locals
time to focus on our country and bring
our youth back home where they belong so
a couple of things about this number one
he is contended that Isis is dead but in
this suite he's saying that Isis is
alive and fighting Syria Russia Iran so
which is it also I've spoken out against
the perception of our troop as a bunch
of young innocents abroad desperate to
come home as opposed to guys who signed
up knowing exactly what they were doing
meaning they were there to serve
America's interests abroad I've gotten
more letters over the last 24 hours from
folks who are in the military many of
whom served in Syria and who are saying
why would we possibly abandon our allies
on the ground there the stories that are
coming out of of Syria are horrific
enough the safe areas of Syria are
basically being protected by US troops
we pull out the Russians are not pulling
out the Russians are staying because
they don't care they're gonna stick
around they're going to continue to
build up their foreign a Forward
Operating protocols and and bases in the
area the Iranians are going to continue
to strengthen their position in the area
the Turks are gonna come in and
slaughter the Kurds none of this is good
I mean if you're Kurdish you have got to
be livid with the Trump administration
at this point the Kurds have been
screwed by everyone they're screwed by
George HW they're screwed by Clinton
they're not really screwed by george w
but they were screwed by obama and now
they're being screwed by trump kurds
right now i mean there was a rumor
yesterday by richard engel over at NBC
news he was saying that the kurds are
looking at releasing Isis fighters
specifically because they want the world
to know that Isis isn't dead at this
point
apparently a lot of Syrian Kurds were
walking up to US troops and begging for
their lives yesterday which is just a
lightful a good indicator that you are
doing the wrong thing is that Vladimir
Putin says that you are doing the right
thing yesterday the President of Russia
meeting the dictator of Russia says that
he agrees with President Trump's
policies on Syria now I'm old enough to
remember when this was a bad thing for
Republicans I'm old enough to remember
when Barack Obama hands it over control
of Syria to the Russians with his fake
red line in Syria then handing over the
the leadership in Syria to Russia and a
lot of
shriek bloody murder over at saying why
would you possibly strengthen the hand
of one of America's worst geopolitical
enemies well Vladimir Putin is very
happy today and there's a reason he's
very happy today no it's to kitty that
he will be withdrawing US troops from
Syria as far as Isis is concerned I
agree more or less with the president of
the u.s. we and I have spoke about this
before have really achieved substantial
changes with regard to the militants in
Syria and have beaten the forces in
Syria okay and I will say that Putin
then tweeted out the the Russians then
tweeted out this morning quote Syria I
agree with President Trump that Isis was
defeated in Syria but terrorists can
spill over into neighboring countries
and regions the translation there means
yeah I agree it's frumpy should pull out
of Syria but also we're not we're gonna
stick right you know for the security of
the world we're gonna stick her head
yeah right well this is all prompted
members of the Trump administration to
go on television and then proclaim that
Isis has been defeated which of course
it has not Stephen Miller was on CNN
Stephen Miller is I think quite good
when it comes to speaking about illegal
immigration he's not nearly as good when
it comes to speaking about Syria here he
was yesterday explaining that Isis has
been defeated this is simply untrue here
he is saying it anyway the president
says on one day that Isis is defeated
the next day he says Isis is there and
let Russia take care of it
Isis has been defeated but if Isis wants
to retrench and regrow and reorganize
it's going to be up to those countries
to defeat their enemy okay so their
enemy Isis isn't our enemy anymore
Isis is so this is now Russia's enemy
weird take Steven Miller and weird take
everyone else all this prompted
yesterday Jim mattis to step down
apparently he did so specifically in the
wake of the Syria decision according to
the New York Times defense secretary Jim
mattis whose experience in stability
were widely seen as a balance to an
unpredictable president again I think
wrongly people were seeing mattis's sort
of the linchpin of American foreign
policy inside the administration I don't
think that's true having spoken with
many many members of the White House on
a regular basis mattis was a crucial
part of the White House but he was
certainly not the leader on foreign
policy when it came to deciding what
what
next for example mattis was a big
opponent of pulling out of the Iran
nuclear deal obviously the Trump
administration did so mattis was not a
fan of the Jerusalem embassy moves
obviously the Trump administration did
so I think both of those decisions were
right so it's not like mattis was
infallible or was right on everything
but having somebody with actual
experience in the military directing the
Pentagon with a perspective on whether
we should pull troops out of volatile
areas I think that was valuable well he
resigned on Thursday according to The
Times in protest of President Trump's
decision to withdraw American forces
from Syria and his rejection of
international alliances mr. Madison
repeatedly told friends and aides over
recent months that he viewed his
responsibility to protect the United
States as 1.3 million active duty troops
as worth the concessions necessary as
defense secretary to a mercurial
president but on Thursday in an
extraordinary rebuke of the president he
decided that mr. Trump's decision to
withdraw roughly 2,000 American troops
from Syria was a step too far
official said mr. Madison went to the
White House with his resignation letter
already written but nonetheless made a
last attempt at persuading the president
to reverse his decision about Syria
which Trump announced on Wednesday over
the objection of his senior advisors
apparently he asked his aides to print
out 50 copies of his resignation letter
and distribute them around the building
and so this brings us to his actual
resignation letter and the disconnect
between what Trump said about Madison
signing and what Madison about him
resigning
so what Trump said is that he tweeted
out General Jim mattis will be retiring
with distinction at the end of February
after having served my administration as
Secretary of Defense for the past two
years during Jim's tenure tremendous
progress has been made especially with
respect to the purchase of new fighting
equipment
general mattis was a great help to me in
getting allies in other countries to pay
their share of military obligations a
new Secretary of Defense will be named
shortly I greatly thank Jim for his
service so very warm goodbye from
president from also important to note
here look at President Trump's language
he talks about that progress has been
made with the purchase of new fighting
equipment a president Trump is very
intent on seeing America as sort of a
business and so when we sell defense
equipments to for example Turkey he sees
this as a win one of the reasons that he
is pursuing a Syrian policy in
conjunction with the Turks is because
the Turks just pledged to buy about 3.5
billion dollars worth of US armaments
presumably they would have gotten that
from Russia if they hadn't gotten it
from the United States but again the
idea that we should be held hostage over
three billion dollars of US armaments is
just ridiculous and
any case President Trump gives this warm
goodbye to mattis Madison's goodbye
not nearly as warm so here's what he
says in his in his goodbye letter and
his resignation letter he says I've been
privileged to serve as our country's
26th Secretary of Defense which has
allowed me to serve alongside our men
and women of the department in defense
of our citizens and our ideals I'm proud
of our progress that has been made over
the past two years on some of the key
goals articulated in our national
defense strategy putting the Department
on a more sound budgetary footing
improving readiness and lethality in our
forces reforming the department's
business practices for greater
performance our troops continue to
provide the capabilities needed to
prevail in conflict and sustained strong
us global influence and then he gets to
the actual heart of the letter and this
is the part it's pretty devastating to
president Trump on a personal level and
for the administration as a whole I mean
it's pretty bad
I'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about your investment
strategy so you may not know a lot about
investments and so you watch the market
with trepidation you may look at the
market and say wow I mean I don't know
whether it's going up or down in or out
I have no experience with the market
well the fact is if you want to get
experience with the market if you want
to learn how to invest the best way to
invest is just by doing it and that's
what Robin Hood comes in it's an
investing app that lets you buy and sell
stocks ETFs options and crypto is all
Commission free they strive to make
Financial Services work for everybody
not just the wealthy I've seen the app
itself bunch of folks in the office use
it I've seen how it operates it is clean
it is easy to use it is really easy to
understand they've charged and market
data you can place a trade in just four
taps on your smartphone the Robin Hood
web platform also lets you view stock
collections as well and gather
information really makes an investment
easy again I've looked at it myself and
folks in my office use it other
brokerages charge up to 10 bucks for
every trade Robin Hood doesn't charge
commission fees you trade stocks and you
keep all the profit again you're
learning how to invest as you build your
portfolio and a lot of people say well
don't do that while the markets going
down well actually that's actually
pretty good time buy stock generally
Robin Hood is giving listeners a free
stock like Apple Ford or sprint to help
build your portfolio
sign up at Shapiro Robin Hood calm
that's Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm go
check it out right now and get that
special deal Shapiro got Robin Hood calm
and get a free stock like Apple Ford or
Sprint's help build that portfolio the
app is just great I've seen it it's
terrific Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm
okay so Madison's letter continues and
he gets into some really tough stuff for
the administration he says one
core belief I've always held is that our
strength as a nation is inextricably
linked to the strength of our unique and
comprehensive system of alliances and
partnerships well the u.s. remains the
indispensable nation in the free world
we cannot protect our interests or serve
that role effectively without
maintaining strong alliances and showing
respect to those allies like you I've
said from the beginning he's speaking to
Trump like you I've said from the
beginning that the armed forces of the
United States should not be the
policemen of the world instead we must
use all tools of American power to
provide for the common defense including
providing effective leadership to our
alliances NATO's 29 democracies
demonstrated that strength and their
commitment to fighting alongside us
following the 9/11 attack on America the
defeat Isis coalition of 74 nations is
further proof so right there that is a
pretty subtle slap at Trump's anti-nato
talk and his rhetoric and it's a slap at
his pulling out of Syria they says we
have a coalition fighting Isis what are
you doing we have a coalition in NATO
what are you doing and then it continues
similarly I believe we must be resolute
and unambiguous in our approach to those
countries whose strategic interests are
increasingly in tension with ours it is
clear that China and Russia for example
want to shape a world consistent with
their authoritarian model gaining veto
authority over other nations economic
diplomatic and security decisions to
promote their own interests at the
expense of their neighbors America and
our allies that is why we must use all
tools of American power to provide for
the common defense again this is him
pushing against Trump handing over Syria
to the Russians my views on treating
allies with respect and also being
clear-eyed about both malign actors and
strategic competitors are strongly held
and informed by over four decades of
immersion in these issues we must do
everything possible to enhance an
international order that is most
conducive to our security prosperity and
values and we are strengthened in this
effort by the Solidarity of our allies
and then he dropped the bomb on Trump he
says because you have a right to have a
Secretary of Defense whose use are
better aligned with yours on these and
other subjects I believe it is right for
me to step down from my position as
brutal that is brutal it's subtle but
it's brutal I mean that is a cut that
goes deep because basically he's saying
I respect our allies I believe in a
strong national defense I believe we
need to confront China and Russia rather
than backing away from them I believe
that we need to not abandon NATO and not
abandon Syria and I have this moral view
of a foreign policy you don't so I think
you deserve a Secretary of Defense who
agrees with you I'm
that is that is rough stuff that is
rough stuff he says I very much
appreciate this opportunity to serve the
nation and our men and women in uniform
signs General James Madison okay it very
brutal stuff not a single word of praise
for president Trump which is unusual in
a resignation letter it's particularly
unusual in this administration where
every resignation letter contains
fulsome praise for the President of the
United States this is having some pretty
brutal impacts inside the Republican
Party I'll explain that in just a second
so a lot of Republicans I'm getting
texts from people who are will Trump
fans people who are deep Trump believers
very disquieted about Madison's
resignation about his policy in Syria
President Trump's policy in Syria about
the criminal justice reform that went
through earlier this week about the
masked nations on the wall which we'll
get to in just a second Fox News
reporter I'm trying to remember name
Jennifer Jennifer Griffin she spoke
yesterday on Fox News about what is
happening over at the Pentagon she said
the morale has never been lower over at
the Pentagon because mattis was
well-liked I was told by a very
well-placed source here in the Pentagon
that morale has never been lower at
meetings here at the Pentagon of the top
brass in the last few days to discuss
the pullout of troops from Syria you can
see that the worm is starting to turn a
little bit for some members of from
space Fox & Friends co-host Brian
Kilmeade a really nice guy a friend of
mine Brian Kilmeade who's been a very
very strong Trump supporter throughout
his administration and before he said
that President Trump today had refounded
Isis and was giving Russia a big win he
was talking with Sarah Huckabee Sanders
he said he's also doing exactly what he
criticized President Obama for doing
here's what kill me it had to say
Secretary of Defense mattis has decided
to retire in a lengthy letter I looked
everywhere Sarah now any praise for the
president president praised him he's
leaving basically it seems because of
the way the president treats our allies
in his view and the pullout in Syria and
Afghanistan seems to have been too much
how bad is the relationship right now
they continue to have a good
relationship but they disagree on a
number of fronts that hila outlined and
but at the end of the day the American
people elected one person to be the
commander-in-chief and to make decisions
well kill me then just slammed her he
said
president Trump sorry president Trump
accused President Rome accused Obama of
Isis and then he said President Trump
just refounded Isis because they have
30,000 men there they're already
striking back with our would-be
evacuation the president is really on
the griddle with this and then Sanders
said that she'd espect respectfully
disagreed with Khalid and then she said
the idea the president has anything to
do with helping Isis Riyaz absolutely
outrageous and kilmeade said correctly
leaving is helping right this was the
case that was made against Barack Obama
and then Sanders says if Isis wants to
pick a fight with somebody they sure as
heck don't want to pick on with Donald
Trump because he will destroy them and
defeat them except that we're leaving
except that we're leaving again what
drove this decision in the first place
as president Trump's warmth toward a
dictator air Dewan in Turkey I president
know that listen there are a lot of
folks today saying this is the
right move we need to pull out there was
no more firm strategy this is the crew
that always says endless war endless war
we can't have endless war I didn't like
this argument when it was made by Barack
Obama with regard to the Iran deal what
people in foreign policy like to do is
create false binary arguments these
false binary arguments goes something
like this if you don't sign on to the
Iran deal you are for endless war with
Iran you want nuclear war with Iran it's
a lie there are lots of things I want
with Iran war is not one of them what I
would prefer is sanctions on Iran I'd
prefer is maybe think about closing the
Straits of Hormuz what I prefer with
Iran is trying to find the sensors
inside Iran who can lead a revolution
against the presiding power over there
what I want with Iran is containment of
their power to the country and that they
already control but Barack Obama's
people were saying things like know if
you know if you went back to Iran
nuclear deal you want war we got the
same thing with North Korea from
President Trump if you don't back
president Trump's talks with the lying
North Korean government the lying
murderous genocide on North Korean
government and this is because you want
war with North Korea or maybe I don't
think they should be legitimized on the
world stage now we're getting the same
routine on Syria if you don't want to
pull 2,000 troops out of Syria and leave
the Kurds defenseless as they get
slaughtered by the Turks if you don't
leave a bunch of people defenseless to
Isis if you don't want to leave a bunch
of people at the mercies of Bashar Assad
by the way all these things have
externalities no the all of
externalities Isis hasn't exactly been
quiet over the past few years in the
West
Isis hasn't exactly been inoffensive in
its expulsion of millions of refugees
from this area many of whom are swamping
Europe and it but the idea is that if
you don't want to pull these troops and
then you want endless war and
just want to fight in Syria endlessly
and leave our troops there endlessly
same thing in Afghanistan we can have an
endless war well what about the
alternative what about the alternative
which is foreign policies really a game
of catch as catch can and we got to be
honest about what foreign policy is
we've never been honest about what
foreign policy is because we have this
kind of we have this blinkered vision
that foreign policy should always end
the way World War 1 World War two ended
with some sort of surrender in the
Signet and a signing of a document no
war since then has ended that way maybe
the Korean War to a certain said but
even that was maintained by American
military presence in South Korea that
continues to this day the reality is
that war is no longer about simply going
into feeding an enemy and then occupying
the country until it is it is a
western-style democracy at least Germany
had a history of western-style democracy
before the Nazis came to power the same
thing simply was not true in Afghanistan
the question is what's in our interest
and is it in our interest to pull out
and allow al Qaeda to reconstitute and
allow Pakistan to possibly fall to
al-qaeda and the Taliban because that's
a serious possibility by the way
remember that as Afghanistan strengthens
there's going to be spillover into
Pakistan and Pakistan is a nuclear-armed
state I mean there are all sorts of
ramifications to foreign policy that are
uncomfortable to think about but or that
are quite real and the simplistic let's
just bring our troops home stuff it
doesn't work which is why I promise you
that within two years President Trump
will be reinserting troops in Syria when
something goes wrong ok we'll get to all
of that I want to get to the government
shutdown and and the Mexico stuff in
just one second because that's the other
big news item that's coming out today
but first let's talk about how you're
gonna cook these holidays with the
holidays fast approaching with Christmas
fast approaching meal prep is the last
thing you want on your plate you don't
really spending all of your time over at
the grocery trying to figure out the
recipes instead why not use blue apron
blue apron really gives everyone a
better way to cook a lot of folks around
the office have been using blue apron
they've been raving about it to me they
talk about the meals that they've made
and these things are like gourmet meals
their chef's design recipes that use
fresh seasonally inspired ingredients
meals worth sharing on social media in
as little as 20 minutes blue apron takes
the chore
out of meal prep the website and mobile
app make it easy to plan meals each and
every week you never have to worry about
last-minute trips for forgotten
ingredients they send the ingredients
directly to you with the recipe it makes
everything super easy check out this
week's menu get your first three meals
for free at blue apron calm
slash up here oh that's blue
aprons calm / Shapiro's blue apron is
indeed a better way to cook I mean I'm
looking at these meals this is stuff
you're cooking yourself
it just looks delicious I'm getting
hungry just looking at this it's like
Korean style popcorn chicken with
jasmine rice and roasted broccoli and
seared steaks and loaded mashed potatoes
and panko crusted chicken and maple
dipping sauce mean this stuff is gourmet
stuff you're making it your own home
it's gonna be delicious go check it out
right now blue aprons com / pair that
make it super easy and super fast and
super fresh it's great blue apron calm /
appear oh go check it out right now
okay so meanwhile as all of this chaos
is happening with mattes and Syria and
Afghanistan chaos is happening on the
home front to the stock market tumbled
some 500 points yesterday which means
that we'd have now erased all gains
since the start of the Trump presidency
on the S&P 500 as well the US stocks
swooned for a second day Thursday after
the Federal Reserve rates benchmark
interest rates and said it would
continue to let its massive balance
sheet shrink at the current pace you do
have to say at this point that the Fed
is obviously taking a pretty harsh
position with regard to the Trump
administration now there are two ways to
read what the Fed is doing by raising
interest rates one they're saying the
market is wrong the market is incorrect
the fundamentals underlying the economy
are still strong and so we're raising
the interest rates knowing that the
fundamentals of the economy are still
strong possibility number two the Fed is
basically saying look we need to raise
interest rates anyway because they're
just too low we can't have another
bubble that burst so we are tightening
up the interest rates right now and if
that cost the economy across the economy
that explain why Trump is so ticked at
the Federal Reserve it also explains why
Ellison I'm not a fan of the Federal
Reserve on this one I am with Ron Paul I
think the Federal Reserve does more harm
than good I think a predictable rate of
inflation according to Milton Friedman's
economics would be preferable frankly
I'm in favor of going back to a
generalized price of dot of the dollar
pegged to the price of gold so that we
at least have an objective measure of
what the dollar is worth in any case the
Dow and Nasdaq posted their lowest
closes since October of 2017 this is the
worst year for the stock market as
currently constituted since 2008 which
is the beginning of the recession is
this actually going to lead to a new
recession unclear at this point but
obviously indicators are not great today
the Dow is up slightly it's probably
gonna even out today
but there was a big drop yesterday and
if you look at what the Dow has done
over the last month as of December 3rd
the Dow was hit nearly 26,000 today
it is below 23,000 that is a massive
drop in just one month if you look at it
over the last six months what you're
seeing right now is that as the the high
point in the last six months was
Wednesday October 3rd when the Dow Jones
Industrial Average was at nearly 27,000
and now it is down below 23,000 so that
is a massive massive sell-off and you
are seeing that basically you know
you're seeing that basically continue I
think that yeah it's a pattern and it's
emerging and it's it's a serious issue
okay with all this chaos happening well
we could really use right now is a
government shutdown now as I say
yesterday I'm not against a government
shutdown
I don't think government shutdowns
matter very much I don't think people
care about them as much as the political
class chatters about them when the
government shuts down not all that much
actually shuts down you still get your
mail during Christmas you still get your
Medicare during Christmas you still get
your Social Security during Christmas
it's all the non mandatory spending then
the non-essential government services
that that shutdown so what exactly
happens nine departments close about 420
thousand people work without pay that
would be the people in the department's
of Agriculture the Treasury Homeland
Security the Interior State Housing and
Urban Development transportation
commerce and justice all right so fine
hundreds of thousands of federal
employees deemed essential are still
forced to work over the holidays without
pay according to the data compiled by
the Senate Democrats but they're gonna
get paid again okay the idea we're not
going to give them back pay when the
government stops the shutdown it's just
nonsense
so 95 so honestly you could find places
that are going to like float you a
little bit of money for the holidays
well the government shuts down knowing
that in three weeks it's not going to be
shut down you pay them back with 90
percent of their personnel considered
essential the Department of Homeland
Security is hit the hardest again
they're still serving so for you the
taxpayer the answer is that these people
are still out there doing their jobs
it hurts government employees but it
doesn't actually hurt the American
people insofar as everybody who's still
essential is doing what they're supposed
to do the national parks are likely to
close so they say that all fifty-eight
of the country's national parks would
shudder would shudder over the holidays
but you have to ask yourself why you
would shut like open-air monuments
remember Barack Obama turning that did
this during the 2013 government shutdown
he actually shut down open-air monuments
like the World War 2 Monument he put
like
ropes to prevent people from going into
the world war ii monument which is just
silly towns the smithsonian museum may
have the funds from a an open staff said
in a tweet but some of the agencies like
many of the agency set to be impacted go
update that as the deadline approaches
another 400,000 workers will be
furloughed many of them will be
furloughed in places like the department
of commerce oh good news 52,000 staffers
at the IRS are furloughed so if we could
make that happen like on a permanent
basis then I'm all for that
apparently if you are because the
fundament for the State Department is
set to expire on Friday that could throw
a wrench in the plans of international
travelers so okay so you should have
gotten your passport stamped like before
okay like I've been in that situation
but tough I mean what's more important
actually getting a permanent border wall
on our southern border or you didn't
stamp your passport three weeks ago
like you should have so right now here's
where things stand President Trump says
he's not going to sign any bill but
doesn't include five billion dollars in
funding for the border while Paul Ryan
announced this yesterday after visiting
the White House alongside Kevin McCarthy
here was the outgoing Speaker of the
House announcing that Trump was not
going to cave on the issue president
forests that he will not sign the bill
that came up from the Senate last
evening because of his legitimate
concerns for border security so what
we're going to do is go back to the
house and work with our members we want
to keep the government open but we also
want to see an agreement that protects
the border we have with very serious
concerns about securing our border so
the president said he will not sign this
bill so we're going to go back and work
on adding border security to this also
keeping the government open because we
do want to see an agreement okay so you
know that is that Trump is not wrong
about this as I said yesterday I'm glad
the president Trump is standing for this
belatedly now here's the the parentheses
critique okay the critique here is that
President Trump should have done this
years ago
you know when it was before a midterm
and when House Democrats weren't set to
take over in the next 30 seconds and
when he had more leverage because right
now House Democrats figure a couple of
things one they look at the last
election cycle and they see that up
until the last couple of weeks of the
election cycle in 2018 the election was
actually quite close then Trump started
jabbering about immigration and non-stop
and he started basically a lot of talk
about border wars and all the rest and
we moved away from talking about justice
Kavanagh and then the Republicans just
plummeted in the polls and they
lost by an average of 8.6 points across
the country that was the final that was
the final vote counts in all of the
House races so Democrats are thinking
okay if Trump wants to talk incessantly
about the wall let him do it what do we
have to lose we have another two years
until the election they're also thinking
we're gonna take over the house in five
seconds so what's he gonna do then
so Trump picked the I'm glad he's doing
it I am I think that it's I think he
should do this I think forcing the
Democrats feet to the fire is a good
thing I think you should do it with a
house full of Democrats I think all of
that is fine should you've done this two
years ago of course you should have done
this two years ago which is why Stephen
Miller who's quite good on immigration
as I said he had no good answers or he's
at least good on illegal immigration we
disagree on legal immigration he had no
good answers when asked by Wolf Blitzer
why didn't the president do this like
two years ago when he could have why
didn't he get the border wall done
during his first two years in office
with a Republican majority in the House
and a Republican majority in the Senate
well we actually have completed or have
underway a hundred miles but the
president's made clear that he's not
interested in continuing to build the
while mile one mile one stretch at a
time he wants to build the wall by
getting the money now
just like the president was very clear
about for the last nine years leading up
to this funding fight okay and then
Miller got more and more animated over
all of this and now here's where the
Trump administration does have an
advantage the Democrats really don't
care about border security they don't
like border security and Miller pointed
that out to Blitzer he said well they
voted against deporting ms-13 folks they
voted against a border wall they voted
in favor of sanctuary cities he's right
about all that stuff it's also true that
Trump should have done this earlier
obviously but when Trump says the walls
work he is correct and this is a winning
political point if he is willing to
press it so I the the focus on the on
the caravan that was coming to the
border was extreme and overwrought but
his talk about a border wall being
necessary I think that the vast majority
of Americans actually do agree with that
even if they tell pollsters otherwise
essential to border security is a
powerful physical barrier walls work
whether we like it or not they work
better than anything okay
of course he's exactly right about all
of this and he should hold the Democrats
piece afire I will explain how that can
be done
one strategy suggested by the president
is not how it can be done but I'll
explain how it can be done
in just a second first I want to talk to
you how about how you defend your right
so our founders were deeply interested
in protecting your individual rights our
god-given rights and then they gave you
the second amendment which was designed
to protect those rights to allow you to
defend those rights against enemies
foreign and domestic and the folks at
Bravo company manufacturing are
interested in helping you do that BCM
was started in a garage by a Marine
veteran more than two decades ago to
build a professional-grade product that
meets combat standards BCM believes the
same level of protection should be
provided to every American regardless of
whether they're a private citizen or a
professional as you know when I talk
about the Second Amendment I don't talk
about hunting because I'm not a hunter I
don't talk about going to the range
because while I enjoy going to the range
I don't have a lot of time to do it
what I talk about is protecting yourself
and your family BCM is not a sporting
arms company the design engineer
manufactured life-saving equipment they
assume that each rifle leaving their
shop will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
oversees every component of a BCM rifle
is hand - assembled and tested by
Americans - a life-saving standard BCM
feels a moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that will not
fail the user when it's not just a paper
target when god forbid you actually have
to use a gun to protect yourself to
learn more about bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG comm where you can discover
more about their products special offers
and upcoming news that's Bravo Company
MFG comm and if you want to find out
more about BCM and the awesome people
who found it and run it go check out
their products at youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA an awesome company I'm
proud to be associated with them Bravo
Company MFG comm go check them out right
now ok I have a lot more plus we have
the mailbag coming up a lot more goodies
things I like things I hate it's the
last episode of the year what better
time for you to subscribe get yourself
an early Christmas present go do it
right now subscribe for $9.99 a month
get the rest of this show live Clavin
show live Noel's show live and coming in
January to additional hours of me of moi
I am here slaving away to bring you the
best in content the least you can do is
subscribe go check it out for $9.99 a
month also we have new daily water
backstages you can be part of the
mailbag on both the back stage and on my
show so many goodies coming you're not
gonna believe the goodies they're really
a lot of good stuff happening and with
the annual subscription you get this the
very greatest in beverage vessels the
leftist here's hot or cold tumbler drink
from it feel the happiness flow through
you it doesn't just provide you with
liquid it also provides you with
happiness I know
because as I hold this in my in my hand
I know that my life is better more
secure more complete yours can be too
maybe I'm investing too much emotion in
this but maybe you should maybe should
go check it out leftist Tara's Hydra
called tumblr ninety nine dollars a year
with the annual subscription go check
that out right now please follow us over
at youtube or at iTunes I know tons of
people have done that this year would
thank you really we are so grateful to
all our subscribers all the people who
listened to the show to all the people
who subscribe over at YouTube and iTunes
all the people leave us for views at
iTunes it's made our show incredibly
popular and allowed us to get out our
message which is really the important
part that's the part I really care about
when I get up every day I can't thank
our listeners enough you guys make the
show worth doing you spreading the show
through word of mouth means everything
to me and spreading the ideas more
importantly even than the show spreading
the ideas word of mouth is deeply
important that's how we are going to fix
the country and save the country and
preserve our institutional ideals when
you join the team I really think that's
what you're doing that's why I do this I
was doing this long before we were all
this poppy I've been doing this for
literally half my life because I care so
much about these ideas and it's a
pleasure and an honor to have you on the
team as well so go over and subscribe if
you haven't already because you should
be part of the team too we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so what exactly should President Trump
do well President Trump should not call
for an end to the filibuster when it
comes to funding the government the
reason being last time somebody tried to
end a filibuster was Harry Reid he ended
the judicial filibuster and that allowed
President Trump to ram through every
judge he could ever possibly want in a
million years has been great for
Republicans why would you want to end
the filibuster five minutes before Nancy
Pelosi takes over the house that does
not make any sense why would you want to
end the filibuster a couple of years
before an election that is likely to not
go well for Republicans in the Senate
does that make any sense under that
makes any sense and Mitch McConnell
isn't going to do it Mitch McConnell
isn't going to do any of that stuff so
there's that what exactly should
Republicans do at this point what
Republicans probably should do is
something that my friend Daniel Horowitz
over at CR TV has recommended he says
that basically he should force the
Democrats to actually filibuster so the
dirty little secret about filibustering
is that it takes 60 votes to break a
filibuster but a filibuster is an actual
procedure it's not just we decide we
filibuster we vote and now we filibuster
no you actually have to go out there and
talk and talk and talk and talk you have
to physically go out there and hold up
the business of the Senate and so Trump
for optics reason should do this so
here's what Daniel Horowitz says and
this is basically correct he says
senators don't need unanimous consent to
bring up a bill the lack of unanimous
consent or 60 votes doesn't table a bill
it's just that opposing senators in the
minority can request to be recognized
and then continuously hold the floor in
recent years majority parties have never
made the minority do that sometimes it
makes sense to preemptively achieve an
agreement because the majority just
can't afford to chew up endless days on
debate of a single issue but sometimes
there are issues worth fighting for
either way this is the end of the line
for the hundred and fifteen 'this how do
you get democrats to stop talking this
is where a senate rule 19 the to speech
rule comes into play the rule explicitly
prohibits individual senators from
speaking more than twice upon any one
question in debate on the same
legislative day given that republicans
preside over the chair and control of
the floor they can refuse to officially
adjourn
opting only to recess temporarily and
keep the Senate in the same legislative
day indefinitely this will ensure that
even the Democrats who are willing and
able to speak for a long time will
eventually be forced to relent this
never happens it's never enforced
because Republicans never force
Democrats to hold the floor in the first
place and Mitch McConnell won't bring up
legislation without a unanimous consent
or 60 votes but if he forced the
minority to hold the floor and enforce
the rule 19 Democrats would exhaust
themselves very quickly it's a strategy
laid out by James Wallner who's an
expert on Senate procedure Wallner
points out the Democrats do have the
ability to challenge rulings of the
chair and bring up points of order or
call for quorum calls as means of
prolonging their floor time but
Republicans can dispense with those
motions with 51 votes eventually
Democrats who've run out of steam and
exhaust their two speeches per member
this could take days or weeks but it
depends on the determination of each
side he says the optics are also really
good here because again Democrats are
gonna have to get up there and explain
why they're holding up the business of
government just to not give Trump the
money to fund a border wall and
Democrats by the way don't have a strong
case here the dumbest weak that I saw
today came courtesy of Chris Murphy who
is just a dolt Chris Murphy tweeted out
today I kid you not that President Trump
is a racist because he doesn't want to
actually build a border wall on our
border with Canada
he said that is literally what he said
he tweeted out that that he said here's
where the analogy breaks down between
the TSA and the border wall he says we
have TSA at every Airport Trump is
advocating putting up a wall in only one
border no wall for the country filled
mostly with white people yes I'm sure
that is Trump's main concern these seven
people from Canada attempting to
illegally emigrate as opposed to the
hundreds of thousands of people from our
southern border attempting to illegally
emigrate if Democrats have to make those
sorts of arguments publicly it could be
quite humiliating for them so if you're
gonna do this if you're gonna do this
why not force Democrats to even if you
lose why not force Democrats to go out
there and explain for hours on end why
they won't fund the government just to
prevent a wall from being built in the
first place okay meanwhile I do have to
note the worst editorial of the day
comes courtesy of Julia Jaffe who is
just a terrible columnist she's a woman
who attacked Melania Trump during the
campaign and then she was attacked by
anti-semites and then President Trump
said nothing about it so she became very
famous on the basis of this
she's a correspondent for GQ magazine
she has a piece today titled just in
time for Christmas
please don't wish me Merry Christmas why
because she's Jewish now as a Jew if you
wish me a Merry Christmas you know what
I'll say I'll say thanks and you have a
Merry Christmas too you know why because
what do I care you're not trying to
convert me and it seems to me that you
are just wishing me
a nice time of the year because you know
I don't celebrate Christmas because I
wear a yarmulke and if I weren't wearing
a yarmulke I don't think would be unfair
to assume that I might celebrate
Christmas in a country where
legitimately 90% of people celebrate
Christmas okay here's what she writes
though she says I like good cheer but
please do not wish me Merry Christmas
why does she say this because she says
it was five nights before Christmas and
my lyft driver was the umpteenth person
to wish me a Merry Christmas that day he
probably just meant to the way most
people do was a kind of December
shorthand for have a good day but he had
a cross hanging from his rearview or I
said thank you wished him the same got
out on my street decorated with lights
and wreaths and nativity scenes went
into my house and sighed I'll explain
why this don't aside in just one second
said I like good cheer but please do not
wish me Merry Christmas it's wonderful
if you celebrate it but I don't and I
don't feel like explaining that to you
and yet you are in the pages of the
Washington Post today it's lonely to be
reminded a thousand times every winter
that the dominant American cultural
event occurs without me oh my get over
yourself lady get over yourself
Christmas is a lovely holiday but it
definitely is not a secular one true it
is a celebration of Christ as it's very
name implies as a Jewish person ID 0
problems with your celebrating the birth
of a person you believe is God's only
son who grew up to die for your sins I
don't share your faith and I don't
begrudge you the joy of your celebration
in fact I often participate as I will
this year when I bring Christmas
presents wrapped in Christmas paper to a
Christmas dinner with my friends in
there sweet children there's no problem
here we know respect and celebrate each
other's differences my family even
celebrated a version of this holiday for
decades in the Soviet Union run as it
was by the self-declared militant
godless Christian Christmas was a second
what holiday it was called New Year's
and then she says when we came to the
United States
we brought ornaments some of which had
been in the family for generations for
the first few years in the States we'd
get a New Year's tree on December 26th
decorated lay presents under it and
remember the new year as as we had for
as long as anyone could remember but
after a few years we stopped it was no
longer a New Year's tree in a Soviet
house it had become a Christmas symbol
in a Jewish house Christmas was all
around us for nearly 1/10 of the year
every year it began to feel deeply alien
precisely because we were secular but it
was not
despite the movies in the shopping
despite the germanic decor Christmas is
still at its core and by design about
the birth of Christ a point that seems
bizarre to argue just look at all those
nativity scenes
then despite its celebration of a
Christian
it is everywhere for over a month in a
way no other holiday is not even Easter
okay first of all when she says despite
its celebration of a Christian God I'm
just gonna put this out there kind of
weird to distinguish the Christian God
from the Jewish God when we actually
believe in the same God we don't believe
Jews and the Jesus part of the Christian
God but we still believe in the same
judeo-christian God right you presumably
the the being standing behind to all
creation right this is something that
Jews and Christians holding calm and
even if we don't believe the Jesus story
as Jews but she's very offended she says
it isn't every ad in every window and
doorway on everyone's lips if you're not
a part of the festivities even its
sparkling aesthetic can wear you down if
you honestly if you look at Christmas
lights and you get sad you got a problem
your life lady as a very Orthodox Jew
again for the 1,000 time I don't
celebrate Christmas you know it's fun
Christmas lights they're twinkly and
pretty and they make me happy because
they're twinkly and pretty and they
don't make me think of programs because
we don't do that sort of thing here in
the United States and in fact it makes
me grateful that so many people in the
United States celebrate Christmas
because those people are generally
standing people celebrate Christmas in
the United States are largely the people
who are standing between Western
civilization and the abyss and by the
way as a Jew these are also the greatest
defenders of Israel she says when you're
a from a minority religion you're used
to the fact that cab drivers don't wish
you an easy fast on Yom Kippur but it's
harder to get used to the oppressive
ubiquity of a holiday like Christmas
oppressive ubiquity I got to say it's
really funny she says this is always the
time of year I feel most excluded from
society one Jewish friend told me I
promise you that the Jews who are most
Orthodox in the United States don't give
one whit about what being wish Merry
Christmas I can speak for my community
when I say the vast majority of Jews in
the United States when they are going
around during Christmas season if
somebody wishes that Merry Christmas we
go thank you and you have a Merry
Christmas too you know why because we
are quite secure in our own religion
it's only secular Jews who are not in
favor of religion of any sort they're
not in favor of their own Jewishness and
unless it makes them other from
Christianity and they're not in favor of
Christianity because Christianity is a
religion these people are the ones who
get deeply offended in fact there's a
famous story I think I've told it on the
program before where a couple of rabbis
very famous rabbis were they went to
public school in the United States and
they were in the back of a cab together
around Christmastime and once
the other so where did you go to middle
school nationwide wants public school
and the other ones who I was public
school too so I don't believe you and
the other one said okay well I did and
the other one said well you know what
prove it sing silent night and so these
two rabbis in the back of the car
singing silent night because guess what
we live in a country that is founded on
judeo-christian values it was founded
mostly by Christians and is still
inhabited mostly by Christians that's
not a bad thing that's a very good thing
that's why the country is so great it's
why the country is so tolerant it's why
Julia Jaffa can write stupid columns in
the Washington Post moaning about how
people say Merry Christmas to her it's
just ridiculous she says says my wish
this holiday season is for people not to
make assumptions about others to put
themselves in other shoes to respect
others as they wish to be respected so
respondent asked with kindness even when
they disagree to live and let live well
if they say Merry Christmas to you and
you're not living in letting live I
would suggest that you're the one who's
intolerant and being kind of a jerk I
mean the Grinch apparently is real the
Grinch is a real thing and the Grinch
has taken on the the body of Julia Jaffe
so good stuff there Julia well done okay
time for some mail bag so let's mail bag
it up a little bit because it's the last
mail bag of the year I know we're all
sad about the don't worry time continues
to move and we will be back in the New
Year with so many goodies we'll make
your head swim
okay Daniel says hey Ben can you go
ahead and get into more detail by turkey
filling in the power vacuum in Iraq and
getting more power in the region is bad
for the US or Israel
aside from being a dictatorship Turkey
isn't likely to attack Israel or start a
proxy war and doesn't pose a threat to
u.s. citizens well Turkey in fact has
backed the has backed Hamas right
remember the the Hamas flotilla that was
backed by Turkey came from Turkey air
Dewan is a radical Islamist who has
helped cut off material military ties
between Israel and Turkey era it would
not be foreign for erawan to start
backing terrorist groups that does not
seem implausible not only that but
expanding of turkeys reach into places
like Syria and the slaughter of the
Kurds who have been our historic US
allies that is indeed a problem air
tawan is a bad actor in the world Jacob
says hey Ben I've recently found out
that my wife and I are expecting our
first child in August we're planning on
surprising our parents with this good
news on Christmas Day and the advice on
what to expect how did you tell your
parents about your first child thanks
and God bless
well first of all grandparents are gonna
be happy okay they being
Grandparent is like the happiest thing
in the world if I can take any cues from
my parents and my wife's parents III
would get ready for excitement and fun
unless unless your parents are terrible
people in which case you know not much I
can do for your bud nah but it should be
a tribute blast me congratulations that
is awesome news the way we told my
parents is we had them come over for
dinner and then I said I just have some
good news for you guys and you know
where my wife is pregnant and and they
freaked out and then my wife's parents
freaked out it's it's really it's a
blast it's it's kind of it's one of the
coolest things in life is telling your
parents that you are now carrying on the
the regeneration of the species it's
pretty cool thing John says I'm sure
someone has already asked this but if a
OC runs like Vox suggestible you throw
your hat in the ring for a chance to
finally get that debate it could save
you that 10 K as well thanks love the
show and clave ins as well
well I can't credit you for your taste
but when I throw my hat in the ring just
to debate AOC again I think that primary
Nkrumah bleagh I think primary and Trump
inside the Republican Party right now is
bad for a variety of reasons the biggest
reason not the primary Trump right now
is because it would force people into a
choice between conservatism and trumpism
I don't want to force people into that
choice personal loyalty tends to win
that choice I'd prefer that the party
not split and have another civil war
over Trump right now especially because
events are gonna do what events are
going to do at this point
Agatha says your men love the show keep
up the good work my question regards to
the theological understanding of
marriage and Judaism why is it polygamy
as practiced in the Old Testament or
Torah but not practiced today in Judaism
also in Christianity husband and wife
aren't understood as the king and queen
of creation is there similar symbolism
in Judaism thanks for taking my question
well obviously husband and wife are the
foundations of all civilization this
goes back to Genesis and Adam and Eve as
far as why polygamy is no longer
practice so and Judaism is outlawed and
around the Year 1000 by Rob a new Tom
was a very famous rabbi it's not been
common practice in Judaism for hundreds
and hundreds of years the reason being
that it was seen as anti-woman the
reason being that it was suspected that
men could not actually cope with with
supporting that many wives and also it
undermines the the institution of
marriage itself which is why you see in
the Bible that there are there are
polygamy in the Bible but the first
couple is one man and one will
it is not one man and many women and
Nicole says what is your favorite kind
of cookie so I'm going to give an
unexpected answer right here I like
Madeline's which are a kind of a cake I
guess but they are delicious they are
just the best thing in the world
Veronica says let's talk dating strategy
who says I love you first I think it
should be the guy who said it first your
your wife also did you hold hands before
marriage so I did hold hands with my
wife before marriage that is not an
orthodox thing to do so I will
acknowledge that straight upfront as far
as who should say I love you first I
think the guy is almost oh I think the
guy should say I love you first I think
the guy should be aggressive I think
that I should ask the girl to marry him
I think guys who don't do these things
are not guys you want to marry I think
if a guy is stringing you along for
years on end without asking you to marry
him then that's a real bad sign and if
and we have two weird bizarre view about
love in today's society you see on TV
people hop in the sack and then like and
then one will say I love you and then it
gets awkward it's like that's when it
gets awkward now when you decided to
unveil your genitals when you said I
love you that's when it got awkward
maybe your priorities are screwed up so
here's how it worked with me and my wife
so the so there they're sort of a couple
of stories about this the first one was
we had been dating for maybe a couple of
weeks and I and I took my wife to
Disneyland which is the acid test in my
family if you K if you take somebody to
Disneyland and they're cynical about
Disneyland you cannot date them or marry
them because Disneyland is a happy place
and if you refuse to engage in happiness
you suck as a human okay so this is so I
I took my wife to Disneyland on the way
back we're in the car and I said you
know I really like you meaning I want to
take exclusively and she already assumed
that we were dating exclusively because
she just wasn't a person who dated
multiple people at a time but I said you
know I really like you and she looked at
me and she said I like things about you
ooh ooh
I still mock her to this day and then I
say and you know what now we have two
kids so there guess who won that
argument that's right
so I basically she came we went to visit
her parents now she stayed for a little
bit longer what was funny is when we
went to visit my wife's parents she said
this isn't don't take this the wrong way
but I think you should come up and visit
my parents and I was like I'm gonna take
this exactly the way it is which is that
we're getting married that's the way
this is going right because come on I'm
not meeting your parents just for the
fun of it and she
like no don't you know don't take it the
wrong way I knew so we get back I get
back she gets back a couple days later I
go pick her up at the airport we're in
the car and I said you know I love you
and she said Thanks
I was like oh so that went poorly and so
for about a month so I remember the
exact dates on this so the exact dates
were on November 15th 2008 mm mm 7
November fit in November 15 2007 I said
I love you to my wife for one full month
every conversation we had on the phone I
said I love you
and she would say bye and then on
December 15th she said I love you too
and then I said let's get married
because she had this is the thing she
knew that as soon as she said I love you
the reason she wasn't saying it is
because she knew that as soon as she
said I love you that was the next step
we were not dating for non-marriage we
were not dating for fun we were dating
for marriage so once she said I love you
there was only one step left and that
was let's get married then I said she
says but she said I love you she said I
love you too and I said let's get
married and she said why can't we just
enjoy our time together and I said
because I'm not enjoying our time
together without the prospect of
marriage before me because this is
rather agonizing like if I'm in love
with you and you're in love with me but
we're leaving a door open I I hate this
this is garbage
so why don't we just get married and she
was real mostly was about choose what
she was 20 she was afraid of telling her
parents she was she's freaked out about
getting married that young and and so we
had some conversations about it and then
finally she said the most romantic words
that my wife has ever said to me she was
worried about what people would think if
she was 20 because we're talking this
through and she looked at me and she
said people are full of bleep most
romantic words my my wife ever said to
me I love my wife she's the best and
then she said so let's get married and
then we were engaged
that was our that was my engagement
story right there was no fancy
helicopter dropping down onto a field
there was not me swimming across an
ocean with a ring on my back being
carried by a laser eyed shark or
anything it was it was me just saying
let's get married and her finally
acquiescing and then it took her a week
to tell her parents so that's about when
we were engaged on December 22nd I
believe she told her maybe maybe three
days I had to tell her parents so that
was that that's our that's our story but
yes the man should say I love you first
because men should be aggressive men it
should be the men in a relationship and
that's what women
by the way okay let's see what else Eric
says Ben if President Trump or a
Democrat and with a progressive left
agenda and ideals you think the media
and celebrities would cover and react
him differently than they do today of
course they would he would be look at
this man he's amazing he came out of
nowhere he's a celebrity and he won the
presidency it's unfreaking real look at
this guy what political skills he has
and look at the bravery and withdrawing
from Syria and look at how he's bucking
the establishment and look at how how
unpredictable he is and look how unique
he is in his connection with the people
yes of course he'd get nothing but
plaudits from the media they would love
him love him love him to death and if he
fibs every so often that's just because
he talks the way regular people talk
basically the way that the way that Bill
and Mitchell covers Donald Trump is the
way the mainstream media would cover
Donald Trump if Donald Trump were a
Democrat Cheryl says hi Ben I read a
story this week about a group called
Freedom From Religion Foundation they
were angry that a large lit up cross was
put on display by the city of Ozark
Missouri on public land the group of
triggered people threatened to sue the
city on the basis of the Establishment
Clause
what's the legality of local government
setting up crosses or nativity scenes my
understanding is that the legality
understood Supreme Court law is that you
also have to provide space for other
religions if they wish to make a holiday
display which is why you'll see sort of
these holiday displays where there's a
menorah there's also a Christmas tree
and a nativity scene and and various
other kind of religious accoutrements I
think all that's stupid it's not an
establishment of religion to put up a
Christmas tree nobody's being forced to
abide by that and but and if you're
worried about taxpayer dollars being
spent for that then maybe you should
just have private groups cover the fee
which is very often what happens in
these cases Williams says if someone is
non-negotiable against a certain issue
like abortion how should they approach
their spending habits when presented
with buying items from businesses to
support what they are against like
Starbucks contributing money to Planned
Parenthood what are your thoughts on
personally boycotting the business so my
general thought on boycotting business
is if the business itself is engaged in
the thing that you don't like then it is
fair to boycott the business if a person
who's associated with the company is
engaged in that not not fair so
boycotting chick-fil-a because Dan Cathy
is anti-same-sex marriage is stupid
boycotting Starbucks if Starbucks I
don't know if this is true if Starbucks
is in a corporate way supporting Planned
Parenthood I think that's perfectly
appropriate
Craig says hi Ben do you think
incivility in the House and Senate
started with Newt Gingrich aided by Rush
Limbaugh well whatever sees no
incivility in the House and Senate has
been around forever somebody was nearly
beat to
in 1856 on the floor of the Senate
Charles Sumner was nearly Kane to death
on the floor of the Senate so no
incivility to not start in 1998 so I did
not think that that is correct I know
you I know that you want this to be the
last question or wanted that one to be
but tough I'm gonna do one more so it
says let's see do to do to do because
the last question of the year so okay
this last question there okay fine so
Renee says had hay been ever considered
writing a book on parenting well I
really write books about what should be
taught to everyone and it's equally
applicable to children I'd feel a little
awkward writing a book about parenting
considering that I have kids who are
four and a half and two and a half so I
don't know how they're going to turn out
yet and if they turn out to be serial
killers that book is not going to be
worthwhile I don't think they will be by
the way they're pretty nice kids Aaron
says Ben you've been very upfront about
your objections to public sector unions
what are your thoughts on private sector
unions that compete in the free market
so as I said yesterday or a couple of
days ago on the on the conversation with
Alicia Krauss I'm fine with private
sector unions so long as they're not
kneecapping people ben says given the
increasing amounts of social media t
platforming that has gone on as well as
the recent issues with patreon it
appears those on the left and right are
increasingly finding themselves
relegated to completely different forums
for communicating their ideas which I
fear will further polarize the American
people was this trend of social media
censorship sustainable or will it at
some point collapse under its own weight
I think it well I mean I think the
patreon is an obvious example of people
pulling out and there will be new more
open fora that are created that have
less of a heavy hand placed on them from
above okay final question of the year
Joel says hey Ben big fan I was hoping
to get your opinion on a statement I
heard recently to understand racism you
need to understand power dynamics to
understand sexism you need to understand
power dynamics to understand poverty you
need to understand power dynamics to
understand power dynamics you need to
listen and believe the stories of the
powerless Wow I have rarely seen such a
bunch of horse crap cobbled together in
a nearly
understandable paragraph before so this
is this is one of the lies that folks
say they say that if you want to
understand racism you have to understand
that racism can only be perpetuated by
these strong on the weak this is a lie
racism is a frame of mind you can be
racist against a powerful person just as
you can be racist against a non powerful
person the same thing is true of sexism
you can hate women and be powerful you
can also hate women and be not powerful
there are plenty of poor people who
don't have a lot of power in American
society who are plenty sexist to
understand poverty you need to
understand power dynamics this the
assumption is that poverty is created by
people on the on the top of the
hierarchy who are forcibly attempting to
cram down rules on people on the bottom
of the hierarchy in a free society this
is a bunch of nonsense and in a non free
society this is true in a non free
society like say a communist society the
people who are rich are the people with
the power but in a free society you can
have people with power not rich
you can have people with riches who are
not powerful and the question is whether
you can become one of these people can
you just a free citizen become a rich
and powerful person if the answer is yes
then this is not about power dynamics
this is about personal choice and they
say to understand power dynamics you
need to listen and believe the stories
of the powerless well no because I don't
believe that human beings are innately
trustworthy so I don't understand why I
would believe the stories of the
powerless any more than I believe the
stories of the powerful I'm only gonna
believe stories that have an evidentiary
basis to them so provide me evidence I
believe it don't provide me evidence I
won't believe it that's the end of it it
doesn't matter who you are and if we
aren't rujuta cating whether you are
believable or not based on your level of
victimhood then this is you placing
evidence outside the realm of reality
and you instead be it's basically
religion at that point basically at that
point you're just taking on faith
somebody's story because you want to
believe their story okay time for some
things I like and one thing that I hate
so things that I like it's been
Beethoven all week which is a great way
to close out the year this is a little
bit of Beethoven's piano concerto number
one second movement Murray pariah on
piano wonderful pianist Georg Schulte
conducting and if you've been in a bad
mood and you want to get in a good mood
listen to some of Beethoven's piano
concerto number one a magnificent piece
of music
[Music]
I could play this for you all day
because it is that incredible Beethoven
God's gift to humanity just spectacular
spectacular stuff and be grateful for
for you know the great art that makes
life that much richer just incredible
incredible stuff okay I have to leave
you in terms of things I like this year
with a thing that I definitely like a
British Army sniper once killed six
terrorists with a single bullet nothing
could make me happier than this is just
fantastic a British Army sniper
according to the UK son once killed six
terrorists with a single bullet from one
of the Army's most powerful guns the
unidentified marksman Lance Corporal and
the Coldstream Guards hit the target
from about nine hundred and thirty yards
away well in Cochrane in southern
Afghanistan so that is a long distance
and for those who don't do math that's
like almost three thousand feet all six
terrorists were killed with a single
bullet why because it hit the trigger of
a suicide bombers best which exploded
killing everyone around him which is
awesomesauce the marksman was twenty at
the time he was using an l1 15 a3 gun
which is one of the most powerful sniper
weapons woodturning Colonel Richard
slack was commanding officer of the nine
twelve royal Lancers explained how the
shot happened in December 2013 when
hundreds of British and Afghan soldiers
were in a gun battle with fifteen to
twenty insurgents the guy was wearing a
vest he was identified by a sniper
moving down a tree line and coming up
over a ditch had a shawl on it rose up
the sniper saw he had a machine gun
they're in contact he was moving to a
firing position the sniper engaged him
and the guy exploded there was a pause
on the radio and the sniper said I think
I've just shot a suicide bomber the rest
of them were killed in the blast the
vest had apparently 20 kilos of
explosives 44 pounds of explosives in it
it was first reported that with that
snipers first shot on that tour of duty
he killed a Taliban machine gunner from
1,500 yards yeah man that's some solid
stuff so well done unnamed army sniper
who killed six terrorists with a single
bullet awesome awesome stuff hopefully
that sort of math will continue to take
place over the course of our near future
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
things that I hate this is a dumb thing
but it's indicative of our dumb our dumb
time so this is a story from Huffington
Post repository of dumb things
it comes from their entertainment
section Disney's trademark for Hakuna
Matata is cultural appropriation
petition claims movie RI audiences in
many parts of the world associate the
Swahili phrase Hakuna Matata with
Disney's 1994 animated classic The Lion
King but one activist is rallying to
change that Shelton ma powwow who's in
Zimbabwe and heritage and based in
Toronto launched an online petition
earlier this month calling on Disney to
give up its trademark for Hakuna Matata
calling it an assault on the Swahili
people and Africa as a whole okay if you
think that's an assault on Africa to
trademark a phrase meaning no worries
sung by a cartoon meerkat and boar I
gotta say you might want to shift your
private some bad stuffs happening in
Africa right now not involving cartoon
meerkats and wild boars that fart on
screen you might want to actually you
know like reprioritize your life just a
little bit so this guy wrote Hakuna
Matata has been used by most his WA
Healy speaking countries such as
Tanzania Kenya Uganda Rwanda Burundi
Mozambique and the Democratic Republic
of Congo it isn't it can't be allowed to
trademark something that it didn't
invent you know what people didn't
invent you know most people who get
trademarks what they didn't invent is
English right so we are trademarking my
slogan okay but let me trademark myself
I didn't invent any of the words in my
slogan
and in fact my people the Jews they
didn't speak English originally so I am
culturally appropriating the language of
English with words I did not invent in
an order that I may have created but I'm
sure has been used at some time by
somebody else sometime in the past maybe
whoa cultural appropriations galore
public records show that Disney first
applied for the still active trademark
in 1994 the same year that Lion King
debuted in theaters that means the
company can potentially sue if the words
Hakuna Matata appear on unauthorized
clothing and products which they should
because the reason that most people are
using that is not because they come from
any of these countries but because they
have seen the movie The Lion King and a
Kenyan intellectual property and
entertainment Lloyd recited with Disney
and the social media dispute said East
Africans or whoever speaks Swahili are
not restricted from using the phrase the
conversation on the Internet's been
blowing up because of a misconception
and misunderstanding around intellectual
property law right but law doesn't
matter an intellectual property law
doesn't matter and wisdom doesn't matter
and reason doesn't matter all the
matters is that someone somewhere is
offended well how about this this
Christmas season instead of being
offended by out of anything or
everything instead of being offended
when someone says Merry Christmas or
Hakuna Matata how about stop being a
stick-in-the-mud you dopes how about we
all have a really nice Christmas
vacation how about we all come back
refreshed in the new year
ready to do battle over the things that
metal and have conversations and
discussions about those things how about
we all come back in a better mood
because I promise you by the end of the
first week of January that mood will be
gone and you'll be drinking heavily and
you'll be looking at ways to escape the
burdens of your everyday life which is
why we'll see you here that i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing